because now uh we did have him booked uh
for the election of Mike Johnson as the
new speaker of the house uh new kingrich
is with us as you can see Mr Speaker
once again we have a deadly shooting
across the country it seems like the
number of fatalities is going up rather
quickly here uh news is a bit sketchy
your reaction to the initial reports
here well I mean first of all it's
horrible and I think that we're going to
have to really think through a better
meth meod of protecting people uh
frankly in states that have uh concealed
carry and other permits constitutional
Carry Permits you have a much more rapid
response to these kind of people who are
crazy uh and uh we have no idea what
this person's motivation was but I think
we have to assume as we move forward the
people and by the way this also applies
to what happened in Israel uh when Hamas
attacked uh we have to have a greater
ability for our citizens to protect
themselves because it's clear the law
enforcement comes in after uh the
massacre uh but law enforcement's almost
never there to stop the massacre uh this
has been true in Europe it's been true
here uh it's been true in Israel so I
think we have to think about a whole new
strategy because these kind of people
are extraordinarily dangerous are
willing to kill others have no sense of
decency and frankly you have to stop
them as early as possible
to minimize the loss of individual
lives you know 100% uh while I have you
Mr Speaker let me ask you about Mike
Johnson um I don't know if you watched
his entire speech today I did and I
found it extraordinarily impressive um I
know he's maybe not as well known as
some of the other people that were
running for office uh a pretty a pretty
extensive background check that we' have
done today shows he has a very
conservative record um for somebody that
maybe America was not as familiar with
to give a speech like that in that
moment probably not having any idea you
know maybe a week ago that he would be
in this position I thought was pretty
spectacular your
thoughts well CL and I were both really
impressed uh with how solid he is I
mentioned to you in your radio show
earlier that we found out today that he
and Kista both follow each other on
Facebook so that gives him some points
for us but I I thought uh he's he's a
very solid person uh he has very solid
values uh he's deeply religious he has a
great family and I think that we're
going to discover that what he combines
which is really very important is a
solid conservative set of principles
with a very moderate and reasonable
approach to people so that he can
actually unify people across ideological
boundaries I'm really looking forward to
seeing how he works because what he said
today was almost perfect he wants the
the committee chairman to play bigger
roles he wants to decentralize so every
member has a greater role to play he
sees himself I think as the coordinator
of the whole house not as a person who's
going to dominate the house and he's
very very smart everyone I've talked to
today who knows him well is really
impressed with his Integrity his
philosophy and how smart he is well I
don't know if you have any background or
experience with with him what are the
biggest challenges I always loved your
advice that that you give Republicans
often and that is stick with the 9010
issues stick with the 8020 issues the
7030 issues stick with the basic
fundamental promises that will go back
to regular order as it relates to
Appropriations and budgeting uh
certainly secure the borders certainly
remain energy independent certainly come
out in support of Israel uh we we are
now looking at a potential Powder Keg in
the Middle East and our support will be
critical holding Iran accountable is
going to take real leadership and a real
commander-in Chief I'm not sure whether
this President is up for that job I
actually believe he is not so these are
going to be very challenging times the
economy is is doing very poorly uh we
have you know 62% of Americans now
living paycheck to paycheck we have the
highest uh 30-year fixed rate mortgages
than we've had in decades uh we have
inflation that is now still through
through the roof um and even credit
cards some people using them for Bare
Necessities and now having interest
rates at up to 30% as we reported last
night these are tough times for people
Mr Speaker Republicans need to show
leadership
here well and I think what you're going
to find is first of all that speaker
Johnson understands that he referred to
it today he understands from his many
friends back in shreport that life is
hard that this isn't about the
Washington lobbyists the Washington
bureaucrats uh the billionaires this is
about everyday folks in shreport
Louisiana and I think as I saw Steve
scalise today was delighted to be
introducing the Louisiana speaker of the
house I think you're going to see that
uh Mike Johnson is going to in fact
Focus excuse me he going to focus on the
human elements of how do we help real
people whether it's gasoline prices
grocery prices Bringing Down the cost of
living Bringing Down the inflation rate
getting back to a reasonable uh mortgage
level and I can tell you right now that
the Republican budget committee members
have produced a 10-year road map to get
to a balanced budget in the next decade
and I think if if the new speaker will
work with with that committee uh he can
create a framework within which the
country will become much healthier very
very rapidly and I agree with you by the
way they're going to have to be real
collisions with a very left-wing and
incompetent Biden Administration and
with a relatively left-wing Senate and
by the way remember I I looked at this
this evening and chis and I were talking
about it because she's so interested in
how he's doing um this guy's 51 now that
means that the head of the Senate the
head of the Senate Republicans and the
president are all a generation older
than he is and I think that level of
energy and Youth and Family orientation
with his four children uh I think all
that's going to play very well in the
country and I think that if he does
truly distribute power to the committee
chairs and allow the members to talk
among themselves you're going to find uh
that he could potentially do a
remarkable job over the next year and a
half all right speaker G great to have
you we appreciate your time as always
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else